now let's go to Adriana Diaz she's in
Beijing with new information on the type
of missile that North Korea tried to
test over the weekend age around a good
morning good morning despite the vice
president reiterating in Japan that the
u.s. is committed to the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
north korea has other ideas they
displayed their largest weapons over the
weekend including what appeared to be
intercontinental ballistic missiles but
US intelligence has not yet verified if
they're real ICBMs are capable of
reaching the continental United States
but the North has never tested one they
have tested plenty of shorter range
missiles including one Sunday that
exploded seconds after launch US
officials believe it was a solid-fuel
medium-range missile known as AK n 17
it's an anti-ship weapon that North
Korea may have been testing to
intimidate the US strike group that
arrives off the peninsula next week some
of the missiles that were displayed in
the military parade this weekend were
carried on chinese-made ships
chinese-made trucks rather they could
have been sold to North Korea for
civilian use and repurposed when asked
about this today the Chinese government
said that they are strictly complying
with UN sanctions though for the record
China's overall trade with North Korea
so far this year is up nearly 40-percent
Charlie thanks so much